we have been exposing and telling you
every night on this program joe biden
first hundred days
totally surrendered his agenda to the
radical squad left
you know like american energy jobs
crushed and killed
and just gone with the stroke of a pen
opening up the border
supporting d.c statehood demonizing
police officers packing the court
and not standing in the way to have
calls to abolish
the senate filibuster biden is making it
very clear that he will do
anything and everything to extra to
appease
this extreme base in his party but don't
take my word for it you can listen to
the leader of the entire movement
congresswoman ocasio-cortez
she is saying biodeen is now exceeding
even her expectations take a look
i do think that um
by demonstration and president biden has
definitely
exceeded expectations that progressives
had
you know i'll be fraying i think a lot
of us expected a much more conservative
administration
um and i think that his not only what
has ultimately come out but the active
invitation and willingness and
collaboration
uh with progressives in his
first hundred days or almost hundred
days
has been very impressive it's now more
clear than ever joe biden doesn't care
about unity that was a big lie he
doesn't care about
about bipartisanship he only cares about
having power in perpetuity
and avoiding all accountability if he's
even
really aware what day of the week it is
as kevin mccarthy tweeted out
in president biden's first hundred days
he's pulled the complete bait and switch
debate he promised to govern with unity
and bipartisanship
the switch is governed as a radical
socialist
green new dealer and of course with
biden's sycophantic allies and the media
mob don't expect to hear
any of this anywhere else washington
compost
they actually announce that after a
hundred days it's going to shut down
their
biden fact check database why fact check
biden when we just echo everything he
says
and we support him and we're just
propaganda for him here with reaction
south carolina senator lindsey graham
okay um by the by the way what is this
you you and if somebody donates to some
website of yours
even a dollar they get a shot at playing
golf with you and president trump
is that true okay number one i want to
fight yeah it's true i want to stop
all this garbage how do you stop it you
take back the house
you take back the senate so i'm doing a
golf tournament
with president trump this sunday may the
2nd and my campaign is going to auction
a slot
off to play in this tournament you have
lunch
you have brexit with president trump you
get a photo
you play at his golf course in florida
it's going to be a lot of fun
go online lindsey graham.com make a
donation
whatever you can afford put your name in
the hat we're going to pick a winner
soon and you get an all-expense paid
trip to florida
to play golf with president trump and
lindsey graham and we're going to have a
hell of a time
enjoy president trump's company but the
money's going to be used to take back
the house and take back the senate
so if you're out there wondering what
can you do to help lindsey graham.com
enter this contest i hope you win if you
don't win the money is going to be used
to take back the house and the senate so
we can stop this slide to socialism
uh okay to me it's simple i say in less
than a minute
the republican party has to be the party
of liberty
freedom the constitution including the
first and second amendment
it's got to be the party of law and
order safety and security in our cities
the party of educational choice the
party
of the constitutionalists on the bench
lower taxes less bureaucracy
secure borders energy independence peace
through strength
trust and verify and free and fair trade
and
free market solutions to health care
that protect pre-existing conditions
what do i miss
nothing if we don't win in 2022 we
should have our ass
kicked because they're destroying our
country people are
dumbfounded about how liberal the
country will get kicked in the ass
because they're going to ruin the
country
socialism whatever manifestation
whatever form is failed
yeah yeah so here's what i'm telling you
i think the republican party will win on
policy
we need good candidates like hershel
walker who's created a job
knows how to talk to the people in
georgia let's put our best team on the
field
get behind president trump with an
agenda just like you described
and take this fight to every state in
the nation
to save america while we still can i
think it's going to be a blowout year
for republicans
if this election is about policy we're
going to win
i'll have hope if if republicans are
smart
that's to make america great again
agenda that that's the reagan agenda
that's conservative
okay now this is a bellwether year
you're right about the house five seats
away
okay in the senate you can't have a
bigger bellwether
florida georgia uh north carolina
new hampshire they really hate ron
johnson they're trying to
crush him the left in this country all
right wisconsin
then you had ohio then you had arizona
can you have a better bellwether than
those senate races
i don't think so i've never seen a
better opportunity for the republican
party to come roaring back
than i did since 1994. i talked to newt
the smartest guy i've ever met in
politics
he thinks this is a better year for
republicans
because the agenda of joe biden and aoc
is really anti-american
at every phase of the agenda from the
economy from border security to foreign
policy
declaring war on the cops we're set to
come back
let's get good candidates lindsey
graham.com
put your name in the hat raise money and
beat these people so we can take our
country back
why do i think donald trump crushes you
on the golf course
i'm just guessing you know he does that
match because he's better than i am
he's got to kick me around well you're
both better than me
i don't have time for this golf thing
i'd love to have time for golf no time
for golf in my life
all right senator great to see you and
so just go all right
you can just you can even donate a
dollar i guess you get a chance to play
that sounds like fun
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else